it's impossible to stabilize somewhere  where you're stuck at home and you can't  go out  like even just having a relationship at  home yeah  is really hard if you can't get a break  let's also  not forget all those people who aren't  as fortunate as us who don't have these  options  and my heart breaks for them where they  like what they have some roommate that  they hate  and they're with them when they're young  or they just don't have the financial  resources to just pack up and move and  write that check for all those books  covet obviously has the literal people  who died but the secondary  victims family members who you know  couldn't say goodbye to mom or go to her  funeral  people who are trapped in their homes  who have no social outlet and haven't  had one for a while  and are now starting to kind of  degenerate and disintegrate